belarusian leader alexander lukashenko
and russian president vladimir putin
have decided to deepen economic ties
between their two nations during their
recent meeting they agreed on forming
common energy and financial markets now
the move comes as belarus faces western
sanctions in response to political
repression in the country the two
countries have also started joint
military exercises that are being
closely monitored by nato but many bella
russians don't want their country to be
reliant on russia and have criticized
moscow's growing dominance
i'd like to ask
the critics of our integration
with russia
where do you see a burden for russia
there's nothing bad in these programs
for the russian
and belarusian
for the past several years
a lot of work has been carried out on a
package of documents to further deepen
the integration process
between russia and belarus
we're talking about 28 so-called union
programs which are aimed at unifying the
legislation of russia and belarus and
various areas of the economy
and for more on this i'm joined now by
our correspondent in moscow emily
sherwin emily thanks for joining us um
the creation of an alliance of states is
something that's been discussed for
around 20 years so let's talk about
timing why is it taking shape right now
well absolutely this has a long history
um the two countries signed a document
in 1999 that actually created a union
state and which basically allows for the
two countries to almost become uh one
country uh with you know a common
parliament and a common currency and now
in the past few years since 2019
especially the russian side has been
pushing um for a part of that document
at least to be carried out in this new
road map these 28 points that putin was
talking about um just now
before lukashenko
was very resilient very resistant very
um
you know loath to sign anything and has
been kind of there's been a lot of
pushback from the belarusian side um but
now he agreed and i think at least in
part uh that's because lukashenko has
kind of backed into a corner at the
moment before he um his policy for the
last few years had been to kind of
position himself or position belarus
between the west and russia but now he's
under eu and u.s sanctions after the
crackdown on opposition protests last
year and it's really only russia that
has been backing him and propping him up
including uh with loans um and i think
that's part of why we're seeing this uh
this step now kind of as a concession to
russia
now in belarus critics of these closer
ties with russia are worried that
they're going to lead to a loss of their
nation's independence it sounds like
from what you're saying they're right to
be fearful about that
i think anyone who was fearful about
that before will be even more fearful
now uh yesterday during their press
conference about the agreement both
putin and lukashenko said that these
closer economic ties were a first step
that they could potentially provide a
foundation or a basis for moving on to
closer political ties as well even
though both leaders stressed that they
hadn't yet discussed that kind of a
development now
this integration has been an unpopular
measure in belarus the last few times i
was there i always asked people about it
and they said that they were worried
that russia could swallow up uh belarus
and lukashenko seems aware of that
yesterday he he talked about the fact
that that was definitely not going to
happen and that that belarus and russia
are equal partners um in this agreement
but i think people who are scared will
probably continue being scared we'll
have to watch this space essentially
emily sherwin in moscow thanks so much
you